si je veux faire une croisière ou un avion
si nous sommes au-dessus de l'eau et qu'il
se passe quelque chose dans ce dysfonctionnement, vous pouvez
hum si vous ne savez pas
nager sans problème car l'
océan est bien plus grand que je ne le pense
[  Musique]
[Musique]
merci
étranger
[Musique]
c'est un traumatisme générationnel, vous savez,
dans les années 60, c'était la ségrégation, vous aviez
des Noirs qui ne pouvaient pas aller dans
l'eau ou tout ce qu'ils pouvaient faire était d'aller dans
les profondeurs  fin vous avez maintenant des enfants dont
les parents n'ont jamais appris à nager et donc
ils ne pensent pas à emmener leurs enfants
apprendre à nager et c'est vraiment là que
nous avons dû en quelque sorte changer ce message selon lequel
vous devriez vraiment apprendre à nager et
c'est  genre d'endroit où vous devez obtenir cette
introduction et ensuite vous trouvez un amour
pour un sport étranger phénoménal
[Musique]
des enfants à qui nous avons en quelque sorte appris à nager
ou qui leur ont en quelque sorte surmonté leur peur
de l'eau alors pour moi ça  tu sais que ce n'est
pas une question de gros chiffres si j'aide un
enfant à
se sentir un peu plus à l'aise pour nager
euh tu sais que le reste viendra à mesure que nous
grandissons en tant qu'organisation
[Musique]
étranger
vraiment bon en natation et je suis comme
d'habitude  maintenant